[Music]
let's talk bachelorette Becca now we
won't get to watch her journey to
finding true love until her season of
The Bachelorette premieres this May but
it seems Becca is more than ready to
kiss them tell you have a celebrity
crush I understand oh do I
who is it Michael Strahan Michael
Strahan in the limos and you know who
else has a gap-toothed one-time bachelor
hopeful Peter Krause not sure he'll pop
out of the limo when the Bachelorette
starts production tonight but Elise
Becca knows what she's looking for
personality-wise I want somebody that's
honest and loyal yeah let's not aim too
high
Yeah right Ari's ex-fiance he sat down
with Ellie today and dished all about
that hard to watch breakup this is
obviously a shock for you I was
completely blindsided when he walked in
and the second he didn't have his
luggage I was like watching it back I
didn't realize that I said just leave or
get out that many times just leave I
felt like in the moment my brain just
kind of shut off and I was so shocked
that I didn't take in everything the
first one we were there when I already
took Becca on the first one-on-one date
of his season back then it all seemed
like a fairy tale coming to life I feel
like Cinderella I mean he put the shoe
on my foot for gosh sakes it's been two
months since the split and a source
tells ET discussions for Becca to be the
Bachelorette started a week after that
so what has the 27 year-old publicist
learned so far I don't have a good
crying face like note to self to always
wear water profess care from now on
because it was on my forehead at one
point emojis
[Music]